but first the big news Kevin McCarthy is
out as Speaker of the
House Washington must change we have to
break the cycle Kevin McCarthy is the
Speaker of the House of Representatives
and he has failed to take a stand where
it matters so if he won't I will the
office of Speaker of the House of the
United States House of Representatives
is hereby declared vacant there's 222
Republicans up there there's 0 of them
that are not moving away from Kevin
McCarthy they're just not if he were to
continue to be speaker there would be
chaos that would continue because he's
not been honest with either party Kevin
McCarthy is a feature of the swamp he
has risen to Power by collecting special
interest money and redistributing that
money in exchange for favors we are
breaking the fever now and we should
elect a speaker who's better now at this
moment the House GOP conference is
meeting to decide who could be the next
speaker of the house after the shocking
ouer of McCarthy now you'll remember it
took 5 days and 15 rounds of voting to
get him confirmed back in January but
just hours now to kick him out this was
a historic move orchestrated by Florida
Congressman Matt gates up until just
before the show Gates was supposed to be
sitting right here telling me what was
going to come next in the big fight and
give you behind the scenes details of
the ouer but he's in that all Hands-On
deck meeting and can't get out he did
send us this note to share with you I'm
sorry I can't join you tonight I'm
meeting with the house of Republican
conference to chart our future it's been
a historic day and our work is not done
now I think we all do understand the
underlying Point here about governing by
these continuing resolutions we need a
plan to protect the Border I mean that
we need to seriously consider the
billions in Aid that were just rubber
stamping sending out to Ukraine
but I have to say tonight it's hard to
see how what happened today gets
Republicans closer to achieving any of
those goals so the legitimate concerns
may have uh you know some sticking power
but the problem here I think is twofold
number one there's no plan that follows
that's what supposedly they're working
on tonight the folks suggested to take
up the gavel have all said that they
support McCarthy so what's next number
two after contending that McCarthy was
wrong to use Democrat votes to assist in
passing a short-term spending package
Gates and the Seven other GOP members
used 208 Democrats to Al McCarthy so I
guess it's okay when they do it uh and
for all the talk about principles being
at stake I mean Congresswoman Nancy mace
moved to Al McCarthy as well because in
her view he didn't move fast enough on
women's issues
another Ken Buck another congressman is
isn't just a you know opponent of
impeachment inquiries with McCarthy he
just moved forward on this idea of Liz
Cheney being a friend of his I mean Liz
Cheney is friend of Ken Buck Ken Buck is
supporting this Gates resolution very
odd and speaking of Liz Cheney she
reportedly called Democrat Dan Goldman
after one of his TV hits to tell him
that he and the Democrats should take
McCarthy out hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else